it's nine o'clock and this is sky news
welcome to the show where i interview
people who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
they'll be from politics sport business
entertainment public life or they'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times and tonight i'll be putting
my questions to the kremlin in a special
interview with the russian ambassador to
the european union
[Music]
good evening stalemate in ukraine
lasting months maybe years that's what
we're told is now likely and with each
passing day more stories of the innocent
victims atrocity seems to follow
atrocity each one crying for a justice
that may never come
nato has just become stronger after
finland announced its intention to join
and sweden may follow soon and why
because russia has invaded ukraine
starting a conflict in europe not seen
since the second world war what's
russia's plan does it even have one i'll
be asking one of russia's most senior
diplomats its ambassador to the european
union
and that war is putting further strain
on a cost of living crisis now affecting
millions of us the government promises
to help families in need but do these
words mean anything to those living in
appalling housing conditions
one 23 year old student campaigns for
communities at the mercy of unscrupulous
landlords
checked by ministers and celebrated by
communities but he tells us there's a
long way to go yet
also ahead what's it like to be a mafia
boss michael franzis was a maid man now
after years of jail and violence he's
turned his back on organized crime and
seeks to stop others making the mistakes
he did will his message work or are all
complicit in the glamour of the
mobster's life
when and how will the war in ukraine end
is it a problem requiring a solution or
is it now simply a conflict leading one
day to an outcome
all latest analysis says this is now
likely to be a long and grueling war in
response previously non-aligned
countries like finland and sweden are
making moves to join nato but russia is
facing heavy losses in ukraine so did it
make a grave miscalculation
just before we came on air i spoke to
one of the most senior figures in the
russian diplomatic service the country's
ambassador to the eu
well thank you for coming on the show
let's kick off vladimir chivo you are
russia's man in europe and you're here
to talk to us today about the situation
in ukraine but i want to kick off with
this
can we really believe anything you say
and that the reason i ask you this
is that you toured the world's media not
long ago and in interview after
interview you assured the world that the
invasion of ukraine wasn't going to
happen and i've got lots of examples
here's a couple this is cnbc
on the 21st of january
you said you asked
that president biden says you're going
to invade ukraine you said there was no
evidence pointing to that
that's not your aim you are certainly
not you said and then another one the
german newspaper developed on february
the 16th this was a week before the
invasion you said as far as russia is
concerned i can assure you there will be
no attack this wednesday and you then
went on to say no escalation in the
coming week either or in the week after
that or in the coming months that was a
week before the invasion of ukraine
ambassador did you say those things
because you were lying or did you not
know the truth you didn't realize that
the invasion was imminent
well
as you quote
i was referring
to the fact that
a military operation in the territory of
ukraine
was not among
the aims of
the russian federation at that point
secondly
on the 16th of
february
actually i believe i was speaking on the
15th but never mind
i i was
saying that
most well of the
recent wars in europe
none was started on a wednesday
and they proved correct
it nothing happened on the 16th
and nothing happened uh the following
wednesday the 23rd
you said no escalation in the subsequent
period
yes uh as far as the
uh
the following uh period is concerned let
me uh give you a picture a broader
picture of events
of that period
uh and uh refer you
to the 7th of february if my memory
doesn't fail me that was the date
when president zelinski spoke
uh to the munich
security conference in munich yes the
7th of february
and he
actually complained that
ukraine
was lacking nuclear weapons
and that he was hoping that ukraine will
will would get nuclear weapons in the
uh nearest future
and the whole audience
i will remind you including leaders of
many western countries uh
warmly applauded to this blatant
uh expression of uh the desire
uh to violate the international treaty
on this passage that was that was
february the 7th then on february the
15th or 16th uh
you said there would be no escalation
the coming week either or in the week
after that or in the coming months that
turned out not to be true i just want to
put that on record there because it
frames the interview in that russia
repeatedly said it wouldn't invade
ukraine when those troops were massing
on the borders and that is not what
happened uh that invasion did occur but
let's move on to where we are now sir um
when we talk about the situation now the
us's director of the pentagon's defense
intelligence agency said this week the
russians aren't winning the ukrainians
aren't winning we're at a bit of a
stalemate is that your reading too that
there is a stalemate here and how long
do you think this conflict could last
well uh i must admit i am not a military
expert of course and
i cannot claim that i have
the full picture on the ground of what's
happening but
i can assure you that the
special military operation
that russia launched on the 24th of uh
february is proceeding according to to
schedule
it
it is not as
quick as some people would have wanted
in russia
it is
continuing at a certain
speed
having in mind
the various aspects of the
situation in ukraine including
the need
to protect
the
uh
the troops of the russian troops and the
uh
allies of the donetsk and lugansk
people's republic as well as the
civilian population
head the russian army followed
the pattern of the united states and
other western countries
we would have
steamrolled
ukraine
several times by now
but that was never the intention
actually i should repeat
that it was
not the intention of the
of russia to
capture territory
in ukraine it is uh
an operation aimed at providing
uh
security for
uh for the
donbass people's republics as well as
uh demilitarizing
and uh the nazification of of ukraine
in order
to exclude a repetition
to exclude a repetition of
uh aggressive uh attempts on the part of
the kiev regime against donbass mr
ambassador let's break that down a bit
you said it's not proceeding as fast as
some people would have wanted does that
include president putin it's not quite
gone according to his plan
uh actually from what i know the
operation is
proceeding in full accordance to his
plan
otherwise you will have to ask him okay
well if he if you could please pass on a
request for an interview uh i'd
appreciate that um just in terms of you
said it's proceeding according to
schedule uh you did encircle keeve and
then you withdrew the troops to focus on
the donbass
region lots of people would argue that
this invasion has actually been a story
of failure that russia has failed to
take heave to take person to take levith
or any other city
even to take mario paul despite your
best efforts you failed to keep your
black sea fleet intact the sinking of
the moskva to divide the west you failed
on that you failed uh to leverage euros
dependence on your fuel and to keep nato
at bay i i would argue or put it to you
that if that's proceeding according to
schedule i wouldn't like to see it when
it goes wrong for russia
well i believe you shouldn't be jumping
to conclusions
actually it was never the intention of
the
russian armed forces
to capture kiev or kharkov for any other
big city
the
activity of the armed forces was
concentrated why did you encircle kiev
if you didn't intend to capture it
sir
uh
actually uh the uh
actions undertaken at that
initial stage of the operation
were
focused on uh destroying
military installations
like
anti-aircraft systems like uh air
airfields
uh and depots of ammunition and
armaments and that was successful
okay
ambassador just in terms of other parts
of the plan our correspondent alex rossi
is in ukraine he's been in villages near
kharkiv where russian forces have just
recently left and has found clear
evidence of civilians being killed in a
trail of devastation every day we see
reports of the same
was that in the plan as well to attack
civilians
uh it was never the plan to attack
civilians and they and civilians were
never attacked
and the fact that
similar stories are repeated
on a regular basis
actually speaks of
lack of imagination on the organizers of
those provocations like in butcher and
other places mr ambassador just to be
clear that the uh the the evidence is
being gathered by my colleague uh it's
not coming from the ukrainians he is
actually physically on the ground uh in
those villages near kharkiv
well
i must admit
that tragic events are happening
civilians are dying but not at the hands
of the russian armed forces
i'm i'm sure your colleague has not seen
russian soldiers shooting at civilians
well there have been some reports today
of uh filming of russian soldiers
shooting civilians but i i'd like to
come on to that later actually uh with
you
what i actually would like to bring you
to mr ambassador is you are the man in
europe i want to talk to you about
finland and sweden eu countries uh this
week who have made moves to join nato
what is your response to this
well i'm
deeply disappointed
uh and saddened by uh those decisions
you know finland
is not a very big country in terms of
population it's about 5 million or
something like that but it has
successfully been
[Music]
pushing above its weight
having become in the last few decades
uh a major power in terms of
uh promoting european security
architecture we all remember
the helsinki final act of 1975
the
osce
which started as the csc the conference
in helsinki the finnish capital
and
actually
this punching above its weight was uh
a matter of
general respect for finland and its
neutral policy
why
the current finnish government
has chosen to
uh to turn
the country
into a backwater
periphery of nato
i cannot understand so if finland is a
member of nato does that make a right
finland more or less likely sir no
but
as
my government
has pointed out
this will necessitate certain military
technical measures
uh
like uh
improving
or raising the now the degree
of
defense preparations along the finnish
border and the russian finnish border is
more than 1300 kilometers i should
remind you mr ambassador what does that
mean military technical measures along
the border what does that mean troops
along the border tanks along the border
what what i don't understand what that
is
not necessarily troops and tanks but
certain preparations uh definitely yes
like radars perhaps but again i'm not a
military expert to
judge on those uh
technicalities mr ambassador have you
decided to come on uh the show and do an
interview tonight because you're here to
warn of the risk of this conflict
escalating into a wider european war is
that your message tonight
indeed and actually uh the issue that we
just referred to uh
nato expansion in the uh
shall i say north northeastern uh the uh
direction
is another element to that
so you're saying that um the expansion
of nato into other european union
countries and other european states
could prompt military retaliation from
russia is it just words of warning what
is it
well uh it will certainly necessitate
certain
um
cons
rethinking of
the russian
defense posture
and
what we are particularly worried these
days is of course that
while speaking about the need
for the ukrainian conflict to come to an
end
western leaders including leaders of the
european union i should point out are
saying that the fate of this
conflict
will be resolved on the battlefield
so uh the european union i'm sorry to
interrupt but i think actually i find
that in all the interviews i've done
you're interrupting me all the time i
i'm sorry sir but um i what i hear from
western leaders is they would like a
peaceful negotiated settlement
then why are they uh pumping uh weapons
into ukraine
at an increasing speed that will
certainly not help unless they of course
want to fight
this
war until the last
living ukrainian
and
ambassador
mr ambassador let's just move on to um
sort of possible escalation in terms of
nuclear threat um can you explain what
president putin meant when he said this
i have a direct quote from him this is
from april the 27th i'm sure you know it
he said if anyone decides to meddle in
ongoing events and create unacceptable
strategic threats for russia they must
know our response will be lightning
quick we have all the instruments for
this ones nobody else can boast of and
we will use them if we have to
is there a possibility of nuclear
escalation sir
well actually that quotation that you uh
just cited doesn't include the word
nuclear
but let me say
that
the russian military doctrine
outlines very specifically
the
situations when
russia may actually proceed
with the use of nuclear weapons it's an
open document you can read it
is that getting more or less likely as
time goes on
uh that depends on the others
can you reassure us that regardless of
what happens that nuclear weapons won't
be deployed in ukraine that actually
this is about nato
and the threat from nato as you perceive
it
you mean uh whether nato will deplo
deploy nuclear weapons in ukraine i hope
not whether russia would deploy nuclear
weapons in ukraine
or on ukraine why uh should russia
deploy
actually uh
uh as distinctively different from the
united states
russia does not deploy
nuclear weapons anywhere beyond its own
national territory
let me bring you on to um
the issue of war crimes
the international criminal court has
just announced an investigation on the
back of growing evidence
will russia cooperate in that
investigation
uh i don't think so because actually
neither russia nor ukraine
are members of that particular court
which has a very
i would say depthful uh
reputation
okay you don't recognize the
international criminal court do you
recognize the jurisdictions of other
international bodies such as the
international court of justice they
called on russia to immediately suspend
military operations on march the 16th
the un human rights council which has
formed an international committee of
inquiry on uk ukraine to investigate
russian breaches of law the u.n human
rights monitoring mission says it's
recorded instances of russia using
cluster munitions attacking hospitals
and the organization for security and
cooperation in europe on april the 13th
they said the attack on maripo hospital
was a deliberate war crime do you
recognize any of those bodies are all
those organizations wrong
well let me let me uh start my reply
with a question uh from my uh part
where
were all those uh
international institutions uh for the
last eight years when the ukrainian army
and the
nationalist battalions were waging
a
terrible campaign against donbass
when a lot of people suffered more than
40 000 people died
uh at the hands of the ukrainian army
not a single of those organizations has
even said a word about that well
ambassador
it was a provocation
ambassador i've just put the point to
you that if you participate then the
alleged war crimes you talk about could
also be investigated by those
international bodies but look we're
running out of time and i would just
like to ask you because
i think people would like to know
do you think that we can get to an
eventual negotiated outcome in ukraine
and what might that look like from a
russian perspective
well
on a positive note i'm sure we will come
to a negotiated solution of the
ukrainian crisis
when
that will happen i will not try to to
speculate and how that
final
solution will look like in detail nobody
knows but
in principle
it will mean that ukraine
will be
uh a neutral uh state non-aligned
uh without any uh foreign
military presence in its territory that
ukraine will have recognized
the
uh
donbass uh
republics and of course
uh
the
uh
reunification of crimea with uh with the
russian federation
and uh the rest will we'll see in detail
so abbas just to be clear your vision of
uh an independent ukraine would be
uh the donbass would be returned to
russia there would be
a land bridge to the black sea
connecting crimea and uh ukraine would
not be allowed to join nato nor would it
be allowed to join the european union
are they your terms for peace
uh
donbass uh is actually consists of two
uh primarily two uh
uh independent
countries that have been recognized as
such
by the russian federation
the donbass people's republic and the
lugansk people's republic
uh their territory
uh
will most probably
be uh the territory of the former
donetsk lugansk
regions of ukraine
and
due to the fact that russia
has recognized them and actually
established diplomatic relations with
them they even
have opened up embassies in moscow but
just finally how do you think it's going
to end do you think this will go on
for a number of years
well uh
if you allow me uh oh
a personal warning to to the west before
you
burn all the bridges with russia
think of the day after that we will have
to
uh to
rebuild our relations on a new basis
there will be no return to business as
usual
uh the world is changing before our eyes
and
uh
as soon as uh the collective west
to use the uh present-day phraseology uh
as soon as the collective west unders
understands
uh that
russia
is
a country
whose interests
should be reckoned with
and
the
current multipolar world
which is not limited to the west and
russia
it's a
it's a big world besides
europe
north america and russia
and if you look at the
situation on a global scale you will see
that a lot of countries
they may not be very outspoken these
days
but
they share the global view of my country
okay mr ambassador thank you very much
for your time
thank you
the russian ambassador to the eu there
and if you scan this qr code on the
screen now which you can see you can
watch all of our interviews online and
all of the previous episodes of the show
well stay with us because coming up next
we'll be speaking to quejo tuena boa
whose social media campaign is changing
housing conditions for thousands of
people in the uk
[Music]
welcome back at 23 years old quajo tuena
boa has already become something of a
hero for renters in the uk
his social media campaign forced one of
europe's largest house associations to
take direct action and fix the
conditions people were living in his
campaigning followed by nearly 50 000
people on twitter has since been
recognized by the government who has
vowed to name and shame landlords who
breach standards he told me of his
personal story with social housing
quojo thanks so much for coming on the
show it's so nice um to see you thank
you and you're here
uh because you've become a very very
well-known figure for your campaigning
work around housing and the fight for
better housing for your own family and
also countless other people
and i'm going to bring some videos in a
bit about some of your campaigning
material but i wanted to start with you
and your story yeah so can you talk me
through
your own story your own experience and
tell me a bit about what happened to
your family
yeah so i've lived in um social housing
for the majority of of my life and um
disrepair's been a huge part of that um
i lived in temporary accommodation
many times and one of which was a
converted car garage uh which was
falling apart there was damp there was
mold um
just no somewhere where no one should be
living i then um with my my dad and my
two sisters moved um to my current home
now which again was completely falling
apart but we just took it in the end
because it was permanent social housing
so my dad didn't really have an option
because he had been waiting for years
and years for that
um and that was completely falling apart
again damp mold cockroaches no kitchen
no bathroom um mice
yeah so you so you so when you were a
little boy your dad was waiting to get a
permanent home for you on on a what a
council waiting list yeah and you just
kept being moved around exactly yeah um
and
there was a feeling especially for him
that he didn't want to complain so
although the place was falling apart um
in the temporary accommodation
especially because it was temporary
accommodation there's this huge fear and
not just with him but other tenants that
i've spoken to that if they do complain
they're at risk and your dad was a care
worker wasn't he was yes he looked after
the elderly yeah so your dad had
a very valuable job to his community
yeah but he couldn't get social housing
for him and his family no and he had
done that for for many years decades i'm
looking after the elderly so he was
essentially a key worker although it
wasn't referred to that back then he was
um and it was a struggle i mean we saw
it as children at the time how hard it
was for him and tell me about your dad
oh yeah well um
he's
he's no longer he felt he fell ill while
we were living in um
my current property now while it was
falling apart so like i described damp
mold cockroaches and he was diagnosed
with esophageal cancer stage one that
rapidly progressed to stage four but
meanwhile he was being um he was
receiving medical treatment so he was
being fed for his stomach during that
time and he was bed-bound he couldn't
move um whilst there was cockroaches and
mice in the property just somewhere
where no one should have been living
never mind someone receiving
medical treatment
for such a serious illness so he he then
passed away in january 2020 and the
fight continued in regards to
the poor housing that we was living in
i'm sorry i'm sorry you lost your dad
thank you um
yeah that's that's rough um
but your dad being ill
in the house in this these housing
conditions
is that was that the trigger for you
is that when you started the campaign or
had you started that before i think so
whilst my dad was ill that was the sort
of main concern i mean housing was
parked to the side because it was just
about trying to get him better and we
thought he would
but then when he passed away and we
looked back in or i looked back in
hindsight i realized this was just
completely unacceptable how is it not
illegal
and he
was the sort of fire that i needed and
it's carried me up until today because
i'm very very determined that
and that no one should be living in
these conditions never mind people
receiving medical treatment but it's
happened time and time again and i've
seen it so he's very much the driving
force behind your dad's fire yeah that
drives you on and
and i imagine he'd be incredibly proud
of you
you fought for your own family and got
much better conditions for your own for
your sisters right so you
you did that for your own family but you
also campaigned for other people and i
think we have some footage which uh i
was watching actually last night um it's
on you're all on your twitter feed let's
have a look at this is someone else's
house
here you can see um a cockroach alive
in the water still or it's just yeah
still alive now
and i wasn't recording but remind me so
you've got three kids yeah and what's
the youngest how old's the youngest
four and then it's a 12 year old and 10
and a 10 year old and you said your
youngest has even fallen in the house
yeah because of the leak and that's your
landline cable there yeah and that
they've come to make safe and where your
washing machine's supposed to be
and plugged in it's not working at all
so there you've got you've got black
rock you've got cockroaches you told me
that that mum
found a cockroach in her ear yeah a few
days before i went there um when i did
go there she she mentioned after i'd
pulled back the child's mattress and
hundreds of cockroaches came calling out
she said she often finds them borrowed
in her ears in the morning and had to
have a few um removed i mean it's
absolutely slum conditions that no one
should be allowed to live in
but they are unfortunately what happened
to that family if you so to get yes so i
highlighted the case on social media and
they were moved out within 24 hours they
were put into a hotel but i found out
um about two days ago that they will be
moved into permanent um
accommodation in the next two weeks and
it would be completely disrepair free
great um so i'm glad that feels good
yeah yeah that's why i do it that's why
i let's go on to
your politics or your political
influence yeah because
you uh how old 23 years old
were name-checked by no other than the
secretary of state for leveling up and
housing michael gove this week
how do you view that acclaim from
politicians for for what you do
um
well
all i feel
um is that it's about time so when i'm
meeting people like michael gove and
other politicians
it's not a sense it's nice to meet them
i mean having grown up in my background
and seeing them on tv it is nice to meet
them
but i mean the context that i'm meeting
them in isn't great the reason i'm
meeting them is to highlight a national
crisis i think that's happening
um and i've managed to build a platform
where i can now hold not just housing
associations and social housing
providers accountable but also
politicians that um
don't unfortunately do as much as they
need to be doing to help um people
do you feel crossed with him when you
see him given that it's the conservative
party that have been in power for 12
years i mean
do you blame him um
yes i'd say i blame i blame the
government that's been in power for the
last um decade because this is something
that has been complained about time and
time again but it's never unfortunately
been seen as priority this isn't
something that's been happening for a
year this has been going on for absolute
decades and unfortunately for the last
10 years or 12 years it's got
progressively worse and after grenfell
you would expect and you would have
expected for this to be top priority in
regards to regulation and social housing
providers and landlords being held
accountable but unfortunately
what five years on um
they they haven't been and i think it is
a national disgrace but i'm glad that
he's
acknowledged that and it is
acknowledging it and making the steps
and i think every single politician in
um westminster should be screaming and
shouting from the rooftops about this
because i have no doubt in every single
constituency is a resident living in
poor social or housing not even just
social housing conditions in housing in
general and it shouldn't be happening
especially after grenfell the uk is the
fifth richest economy in the world
um
yet you've shown these conditions we are
a wealthy nation a very wealthy nation
you've shown these conditions are
commonplace 1.6 million homes in social
housing or private rented sector failed
to meet the government's good home
sanders why have people been forgotten
in this way is it cultural is it
political what do you what do you think
it's a mixture i think between both and
the the fundamental thing is um
the lack of care like i mentioned before
it's not being seen as a priority is
that because people in government
don't experience it
almost definitely and it's i mean
having to deal with housing is a big
issue and i mean it's not going to be
bringing in money really for them so i
understand why they don't see it as a
priority but it should because it
affects millions of people's lives and
not just that i think it's also when we
look at westminster and diversity it's
very easy to tick a box when it comes to
race and also gender but what's not
looked at is class and the fact that
there's not class diversity in
westminster so how can they truly be
representative of the people people like
me people sat in their homes suffering
in social housing and truly say that
they are diverse and representative of
them because i can tell them frank
frankly that they're not i was going to
ask you this i'll bring it up now you've
pulled it up because you're a serious
campaigner you have a national profile
you're commanding the attention of
cameras you're 23 years old i mean i
can't get over that how young and
influential you've become but you're a
young black man you're a young working
class black man
i was going to ask you what what's the
biggest barrier is it being black or is
it being working class oh was it both
i mean the mixture of the two just sets
you on a back foot completely i mean
there's a stigma that comes
around with being a black male off of an
estate it's never a good one you're
almost looked down upon so for me to be
able to do this i wanted to be able to
show other people like me other black
boys of an estate that it is possible um
to make change and that your voice does
matter because it does and collectively
it change can be brought about i mean in
the last year this has happened and
they've been supporting i have to give
massive thanks to the black community
especially um on my estate and on social
media that have constantly shared this
and been able to to relate to the
situations that i've been highlighting
because for so long they've suffered
their parents have suffered um and
they've just been ignored so if i can
help inspire them then that's what i
want to do with the work that i am doing
as well as creating change in in
government
and you
do inspire people but you have created
change in government um the queen's
speech this week that's the government's
legislative program for the next year
contained measures to clamp down on
rogue landlords which is directly
attributable to you
is that enough does that does that go
far enough for you is that just the
beginning of this campaign for you i
mean it was nice hearing that in the
queen queen speech i have to say um but
i want to know um what
exactly that entails what changes are
being brought about i think there needs
to be a crackdown on landlords both
privately and social landlords they need
to be held accountable with the work
that i've been doing over the last year
highlighting not one um ceo or senior
manager for one of these social housing
providers have lot has lost their jobs
but had it been a situation where this
was in the nhs or any other public
sector people would have lost their jobs
as a result there's not enough
accountability there's not enough
accountability and i still don't believe
there's enough care there too and like i
mentioned earlier after grenfell there
should be people should be held
accountable um within housing and
meeting or not meeting regulation i've
got a few more questions on you out of
time so quickly um
you have made incredible impact do you
ever see yourself being a politician i
think you did once tweet that you might
be trying to be the mayor of london so
you can't say that this comes from
nowhere this question yes um well i
thought about it and i mean for change
to happen yes i know i'm screaming and
shouting from outside but i do believe
it comes from within two so um who knows
i know something so maybe is in two
years i have to wait and see did you
join a political party you joined a
political party i have to say i'm very
disappointed in um both of them at the
moment equally um so i haven't uh yet
um whether i will i have to wait and see
but if i do i think do anything
politically it'll probably have to be
independent uh the way the current
political sofia looks okay
okay so you might go into politics so
you might have a look at running for
london mayor watch this space
right okay you also people might not
realize this you're also actually a
full-time student i don't know yeah i
mean you're very productive you're
clearly not down the bar like i would
you're very productive um you've just
finished your exams i have yesterday
three hour exam in the morning um
so that's my degree
over and i mean that for me was the
hardest hardest thing i think i've done
because on four occasions with my dad
passing away and becoming ill yeah i did
plan on dropping out so to be able to go
and care for your sisters yeah sort
everything out exactly and must be
really hard yeah so to be able to do it
that's a huge accomplishment and i know
that's one of the last things he
remembered was the fact that i'm in uni
and i'm going to finish my degree so
that was are you the first person for
your family to go to university i was
but me and my sister are both graduating
this year wow he must have been so proud
of you all yeah so you you you're going
to get a business studies degree
you said that you're hoping to get a 2-1
i think you might get first i think
there might be some false modesty there
or not well not just genuine mostly
actually and you but you've got an
ambition to be an artist yes that's
always been um my my main goal i mean
from the age of 14 i taught myself how
to paint portraits so um i've been doing
that on the side while studying my
degree and everything else and that's
what i hope to go back into i mean long
term that is what i want to want to do
when it comes to your campaign on
housing how do you define success what
would it be for you you think i've done
it success for me would be when my phone
stops going off and from tenants
complaining that they're complaining
that they've been ignored constantly and
asking for my help as a result okay
crojo thanks so much for coming and
joining us thank you so much it's great
talking to you i enjoyed it thank you
craig he's just 23 years old well
goodfellas the godfather for years
hollywood's been making films about
mafia families well tonight we have a
real life member michael franzine is a
former member of the new york columbo
crime family he's now in the uk holding
a series of events and visiting prisons
and community centers to tell his story
and i spoke to him a little earlier
michael thanks for for coming on the
show let's kick off with your past you
were once a mafia boss
in 1986 you were actually listed as one
of the top 50 most powerful and wealthy
mafia bosses in the world
there's a mystique in a way around the
mafia a sort of glamour and grit
are the portrayals that we see
anything like living it well it depends
on on what you're seeing and if you're
watching a movie like goodfellas
donnie brasco
even bronx tale
uh pretty authentic you know the
characters are portrayed well and uh you
know in goodfellas they mentioned me and
goodfellas and and donnie brasco i knew
all of all those guys and i thought they
did a great job now some of the movies
that you see no but those three i would
say are
pretty accurate when i watch gamora
which is set in italy it's set in the
slums of naples really
it's gritty and it's messy
and it's brutish
and it's a kind of horrible life
actually to watch it it's full of pathos
actually
was it like that quite a lot of the time
like it was a grind
in america there are a lot of
misconceptions you know that people draw
from the media and sometimes from uh you
know from entertainment uh things that
they watch
there is a gritty part of the life
obviously it's very gritty it's street
uh but there's also a a integrity and a
respect to the life
and i think we see that in some of those
movies we saw it in the godfather even
though it was fictional
um and that's what i experienced you
know there is a a high standard in that
life in many ways there's a code of
conduct
yeah code of conduct
uh respect is an issue discipline is an
issue
um you know
being respectful to women believe it or
not you know your wives your families
uh it's all part of that life and there
are serious consequences if you don't
pay attention on your website um
you say yourself that your
own the only
high ranking official from a major crime
family that ever walked away
without protective custody alive and
you're still here and you're very
successful
yeah how did you do that well understand
it's not
it's not something that i portrayed
myself as but uh you don't walk away
from that life i mean you just can't you
take that oath it's for
it's for a it's a lifetime oath
and normally when people leave the life
they join the government enter a witness
protection program and begin cooperating
i didn't do that
um i was just um determined to walk away
because i knew it was a bad life
and i wanted to preserve my family life
after you left did you we you must have
been afraid were you constantly looking
over your shoulder thinking someone's
going to take me out
when i walk down the street here i look
over my shoulder it's just instinct you
know from being part of that life for so
many years i didn't live in fear
because i was
i felt pretty sure that i can handle it
so i didn't live in fear but i was
cautious i wondered as well
whether
your father remained in the mafia
he died when we just talked about it
when he was 103
did he offer you
protection do you think that helped you
that your father
was still active
you know yes and no um listen
when i walked away from that life the
authorities the fbi came into prison i
was in prison at the time and they said
there's a contract on your life and your
father has gone along with it that's
what they told me
you know i don't think they understood
that i knew the life that well and i
understood that my father
couldn't speak up for me at that point
because he didn't know what i was going
to do if he did go along with it it was
only to protect himself because when you
bring somebody into that life and that
person becomes an informant or
cooperator you could be in trouble
yourself for introducing him into life
how did you feel when you found out that
your father had gone along with the
contract on your life you're a father
yourself i understood what he was doing
now i want to make it clear i mean
i don't think my father would ever put a
bullet in my head i don't believe that
he did what he had to do just to
preserve himself at that point but
uh
did it hurt a little bit yeah i have to
admit it did but i understood what he
was doing and i love my dad i mean there
was nothing that he was going to do to
take into fear and the love that i had
for him and the love he had for me i
understood that
but you know the street life is
different and you have to you have to be
careful there because
you know one wrong move could be very
serious
so in some ways the mafia family becomes
more important than your nuclear family
your real family
not for me but remember this is your dad
yes when you take that off
you're told straight out if your mother
is dying and sick and you're at her
bedside and we call you to service you
leave your mother you come and serve us
from now on we're number one in your
life before anything and everything so
you you have that drilled into your head
it's number one
uh my dad unfortunately
uh lived by that oath
to great suffering of his family i mean
i understand i had a sister that died at
the age of 27 odd on drugs my brother a
drug addict all his life became an
informant and testified against my dad
in his case my younger brother my baby
bro what happened to him i put my bat my
father back in jail my brother is now on
the street he was in witness protection
for many years and i wasn't willing to
do that to my family michael can you you
made a made man a made member
um
you were a mate you were inducted in
1975 so 48 years ago it would be 47
years ago
can you just explain to the viewers what
what is that what's that what was that
night like what what happens they cut
your finger right here some blood drops
on the floor i cupped my hands they took
a picture of a saint catholic altar card
put it on my hands lit it aflame didn't
hurt it burned quickly it was merely
symbolic and he said tonight michael
francis you are born again into a new
life and to cause an australia
violate what you know about this life
betray your brothers and you will die
and burn in hell like the saint is
burning in your hands do you accept yes
i do that's the old well let's get on to
london here in tottenham um
you came here to talk about the tour but
also you know in london that there's a
huge problem with knife crime in places
like tottenham lots of boroughs across
the capital
there's an initiative here gloves up
knifes down
would that have persuaded you
years ago in brooklyn do you think yes
these kids on the street i spent a lot
of time in prison with kids coming into
the system 21 22 years old horrible
backgrounds you know get involved in
gangs drugs the whole bit and i used to
minister and counsel to them at that
time before i was a christian i was
still a street guy at that point i said
what are you doing with your life
you know i tell them you know you keep
hanging out in these environments get
used to this because this is going to be
your home you're going to be here for
the rest of your life and you're going
to drive your family crazy if you got
one
so um but yes you need these
organizations because look
you can't just tell a kid walk away from
that life and send them back to the
neighborhood it's dangerous what caused
me when you talk about your previous
life is that the mafia is like an
alternative society it has a family it
has social bonds
intergenerational respect it has a
structure it has a code of contact
conduct it's motivated by a clear goal
which is success and protection of
members
when i think about organized crime gangs
in london
uh they might be less structured
but they also for the
kids that get involved in them they're a
family
it provides them with structure do you
see parallels between
between the two lives no they don't have
real structure and discipline they're
not really organized they're a bunch of
street drugs trying to steal to earn a
living and that's what they teach
it's different the gang life is
different than mafia cause an artist we
were organized crime we had our crime
directed in a certain direction we
weren't going robbing people's houses
and and you know knifing people in the
street and stuff like that we didn't do
that my targets federal government big
banks insurance companies they got
enough money i figured hey if we take a
few bucks they'll survive we're not
robbing people in the street it's a
whole different thing that's not family
michael you've talked about we've talked
a bit about knife crime and and
and inner city crime uh and you do go
and talk to to kids in schools but
you're also here because you're you've
got a tour where you're going to talk
about
your life yes
july 2nd at the grosvenor hotel we kick
off the tour right here in london where
we should kick it off and we're going to
25 cities throughout the united kingdom
and it's going to be fantastic i'm very
excited about it they're going to hear
about the mob life it's part of life i
know what people want to hear i've been
telling stories but i feel i can say
things here in the united kingdom that
i've never said before and i want to
give people a real insight into that
life you got to understand something i
was around john gotti fat tony salerno
did chin
joe colombo these were all my fellow
associates my dad sonny francie's oldest
living mob guy in the world
so i have a lot to talk about a lot to
tell i want to give people real insight
into that life and they're going to hear
it all around the uk and it's going to
be a fun fun deal
okay michael franzis thank you so much
for
coming on the show thank you thank you
well that's all for today's show thank
you to all our guests and thank you so
much for watching coming up the news at
10 on sky
[Music]
you